[Music]
when you drop a stone from your hand it
falls to the ground it's an example of
free fall whenever objects fall towards
the earth on the disk force alone we can
say that the objects are in free fall
the stone accelerates towards the earth
and this acceleration due to the
gravitational force of the earth is
denoted by lowercase G you think a few
mathematical equations we derive the
value of G at this remember this is only
for free fall for objects very close to
the earth uppercase G is the universal
gravitational constant M is the mass of
the earth and R is the radius of the
earth so for specific case of objects
close to the earth we get the value of G
as 9.8 m/s^2 but do you know what's
interesting this acceleration is not
dependent on the object's mass this M is
the mass of the earth not the object why
is this interesting let me give you a
situation when you're on the fifth floor
of a building and you have a stone in
one hand and a piece of paper in the
other
if you drop both together which one will
reach the ground first
or will they reach family neatly the
stone will reach the ground first why
does this happen as its independent of
mass both should fall in the ground at
the same time right the answer to this
if air resistance when objects are
falling towards the ground the a offers
resistance in the upward direction and
the resistance offered to the paper is
more than the resistance offered to the
stone and that is why the stone falls to
the ground first for a moment let's
imagine a room with no air its vacuum
now from the ceiling of the room if a
stone and a paper are dropped will they
fall to the ground at the same time the
answer is yes they will reach the ground
at the same time because there's no air
to offer resistance so this was an
important concept we learned and
other thing we know is the acceleration
G is constant near the earth so this
means that all the equations of motion
we've seen for uniform acceleration will
be valid here can you remember the three
equations of motion here they are here
it can be replaced with G that for
freefall in the next video we will solve
word problems related to these equations
[Music]